i'm like cognitively that no it's just
like common sense that
i'm gonna just bring up the swimming
picture one more time because like like
we said earlier if there
if there were it wasn't no difference
first of all you wouldn't need to
specify between men and women just be
people just be people
yeah and
yeah there wouldn't be no separation
between men and women's sports
period if there wasn't
a disadvantage and if
there wasn't that if there wasn't
something that needed a separation
and
now
there's something that wasn't
popular back in the day when they did
make the
men and women sports that are now coming
into it
and it's like
oh just because you throw
women's behind trans okay yeah go ahead
it's like
but we're forgetting that there's a
separation for a reason and there's a
separate and there's and we have that
separation because of these things that
qualify you as a man and these things
that qualify you as a woman and if it
was equal like men would join them were
women trans oh my gosh biological women
would join the men's league and kick ass
but they don't you only see that
happening one way yeah
and oh my gosh it's just like i i just i
i hear some of these people like talk
that make the laws
that make the law
do you see that do you see that clip
where the girl was like
the girl was like that's a dude it's at
the swim meet and then the guy that
worked at the ncaas was like well are
you a doctor and she's like i'm not a
vet but i know a dog when i see one
wow
[Music]
and that's even when you sent me that
clip where there you go where that guy
was like well you're on hormones for a
year you go through these changes and
i'm like
i don't need a degree to just tell you
this is crazy like this is nonsense and
that was the case i can't tell you the
science i have no idea what they do to
their body
but like come on if that was the case
then everybody would just be
born
just be born and we'd just be
born and then you can choose
yeah
you just choose do you want to take
testosterone for the rest of your life
or do you want to take action from the
rest of your life and then once you take
that
that identifies you as a woman that
identifies you as a man and if that if
that is the key factor then what what
would be the point of us having
having boobs having a uterus having the
i don't know if i could say
the other word
the v word
you could just say that
[Music]
a little kid or cat
like there wouldn't be a point
of
any of that any of it for us to like
have those things as a woman if the
deciding factor was estrogen and
testosterone
yeah it's it's having kids yeah that's
and then they'll use the stupid argument
well some women can't have kids yes but
they still have the biological things to
have kids if this is a genetic like
mutation and then and then
yeah and then the other argument they'll
say is like women
like well you're stronger that's not all
men that'll dominate it's like some men
i'm not like like i could still out i
can outlift a lot like i'm strong
i cannot lift a lot of guys but my
brother who hasn't worked out in five
years can out bench me yeah
and that's just that's just it like
i bet you my little brother that hasn't
lifted weights maybe
more than a month in his life could
probably
outbench me or probably lift weights
more than me just because
he's a man and it's just like
that's like that's like saying like
teenagers versus adults
like because some teenage like let's say
we do a 13 year old division should 13
year olds play against like 21 year olds
because some 13 year olds can
compete with the 21 yeah and that's like
that's the exception there's there's
some some kids that can do that but like
you can't take the exception and then
group everybody in that exception and
it's just like well i'm i'm not that
exceptional i can't play with no 21 year
old like i want to play with people my
age on a level playing field and do you
feel like as a big it's like like
because we're we're we're both centers
right you're you're kind of centered
like i think
it hurts us more because like i would
have no opportunity at all competing
against i'm not tall yeah
uh trans woman yeah i wouldn't have no
like i'm not gonna lie i've played
against guys in like i've played again i
play against guys like sometimes yeah
and there's just certain things that i
just wouldn't even post up because i'm
like what's the point of posting up
against a guy that's like six foot five
yeah is there really a point he's gonna
block the sh yeah
what's the point so
i talk a lot of [ __ ] to dudes too like i
always tell them
i i always say i can beat them in
one-on-one even if i know i'm damn well
i can't
i don't know i'm like guys on one one i
just like completely changed the way i
play like i'll shoot a lot because i
don't want to get i'm not
and i used to beat my last boyfriend
one-on-one all the time but it was also
because he was really overweight yeah
that was the only reason that like as
soon as it was so humbling because he
lost like a bunch of weight when we were
together and as soon as he like got to a
certain way
i couldn't win anymore no it was just
over with
dang
that's crazy and he he played like what
a year or two of high school bat i
played in college i played overseas like
barely still counts
so for
so for us to be able to
compete with men they have to be
physically
lesser than us
like in like just out of shape for us to
be sure yeah we're shorting or super
skinny yeah
actually that's wrong
it sucks it's like the
the trans women that are going into
these leagues are actually athletes but
whilst they were a man so like yeah
they're like physically fit already and
then they're going into the league oh
well they're transitioning and then
they're going into our leagues but
they're still like got the
physicality of a man they've been
draining their whole life yeah so it's
like
yeah
and then it becomes dangerous as a
society because we stop like accepting
what reality is yeah then we start like
i i identify as a child put me in pre-k
yeah
like
i driving a freaking taboo or the day of
my life when these grown adults are like
i identify as a baby
we went like wearing diapers growing
adults wearing diapers and the
it's just it's like you're you're whole
40 we're in a diaper
eating baby food drinking out of a
bottle
if you don't look yourself in the mirror
and get yourself get your tail to work
or something you are not an infant
anymore let's bring back bullying
no i swear to god because i feel like
the older generation just bullied each
other out of this [ __ ] they really did
they were you i was bullied it was good
for me i was annoying as hell
sometimes i need to learn to shut the
[ __ ] up
for the wrong things though i was
believers things i couldn't control like
my height or being top really yeah
they're like well i won't get it
but yeah i can i can understand that
it's just
like all right i could identify as like
native american give me a scholarship
like elizabeth
[Music]
and i feel like it's so touchy now that
people don't go into like looking into
that so you could say that you can say
i'm native american and have all the
information you you need you could have
like i think it's is it 15 you need to
be
native american it's something there's a
certain percentage you need and it's not
you don't have to be full-blooded you
can you just need to be part of a tribe
so in the states there's um
in the states there's uh territories in
um
some states and that used to be native
land and so
if you are native american and if you're
from any tribe you can get a scholarship
at certain schools because you are
native american because they're on they
get a lot they get a lot of like native
american scholarships are like
and so um
essentially they
it's like
everybody just takes your word for it i
could say i'm uh
i'm a quarter or 50 cherokee you
wouldn't question it because i know oh
this is where this land is this is where
this is i research myself and so i'm
able to like convince you
that i'm it like okay
give me my money and i feel like it's
gotten to that to where people just
don't question it they just take their
words and people can
lie
just so easily and it's just